[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
back
[Music]
ah
[Music]
hey welcome back to through the warm ups
i'm your boy pierre aka the plug i'm
sorry for hitting my chest
uh
my audio people they're gonna be on my
ass about that i'm sorry i won't do it
again to my right got your boy d mills
how y'all doing d-mails but what else
they call you
big sexy what else who's that big daddy
d
i don't know anything they go on man
things go off yo the reason i i asked
you this because you see they changing
the name but we're gonna get to that to
my left ain't miss a step what's up
what's up welcome back to the warm-ups
late night episode welcome man
and to my left left he ain't steph steph
what's up what's up y'all
i am you see i did that perfectly with
the lakers running out
man it's about time it's about time they
came out
their banner says 17-time champion
but i did that on cue for you because
you're a laker fan i'm the most
realistic laker fan oh i like
earlier today you asked me deandre
jordan for uh sabonis or something or
miles turner so you ain't really that
realistic i remember when b alyssa was
playing better than kuzma he said that
kuzma wouldn't that'd be a list there
wouldn't be an upgrade but look he told
me i'm hoping he turned kuzma into
russell westbrook so boom that's not
looking too good for you
um before we
continue
what we on with
some [ __ ] uh
that
he just missed the dunk that's a good
sign though take the under that's a good
sign why is that a good sign because
that means he not really worried he just
relaxed he's just you know it was
whatever
realistic like a family is read the
prompt for the people so they can what
you should rename the staple center what
do you all think we should name them
wrong answers only
because like like we said in the
beginning the paper centers is called
crypto dot com
arena or something or something always
going to be stable sentence to us
but we'll never call it the crypto i'm
going to adapt the crypto.com thing i'm
not cause the staples is
is what is it folders and stuff they
don't have no meaning oh man
it's the same dude that say alonzo ball
should be in the gym no it's not
following this i will walk off this show
and never come back that was not me be
yourself stop following him he gets you
down that rabbit hole you might get my
right arm like three fold gangs in they
talking about he belong in the g league
don't don't do not believe the bs that
is coming out of these dudes now
somebody up here said that but it wasn't
the dude now you know me and you do a
daily i'm not a daily but a game we bet
when we do this show we do who we got
who shot you taking
focusing on
let's take a jason tatum back i'm the
over on shot mix what you got i got it
over you gotta go
set a number
let's put it at 20.
damn right he going so high with the
shot i'll take under
we got an early answer with the fishy
center thirty five dollars thirty five
dollars what fish he's thinking i don't
like huh this is this is what we said in
the comments so for the fishy little
fishy [ __ ]
we got a comment i thought was pretty
funny
og totally says life alert center i
thought that was pretty funny you ever
ate a fish fillet no i have what are you
bogus and i'm offering
you ever had a mcrib he never been doing
a struggle mcrib is decent you ate a
fish for less
hell yeah often yeah i gotta have plenty
of official ladies to have us at that
mcdonald's
daily yeah i haven't had a nick rib yeah
no
you haven't been ripped you know you had
to make read before mike i know you've
had him again that sounds like a premium
he's shooting no look shots lebron is
shooting no look shots right now i told
you he's not worried bro that's funny
now if they lose by third another day at
the office but he hit the one where he's
paying attention
speaking of lebron james before you read
that comment mike i'm gonna let you read
it first because it looks like flop city
center
very wrong everybody keeps saying look
arena mamba arena we don't we're not
gonna put wrong answers on right
sounds that would be something we down
with it's so predictable y'all y'all
becoming predictable
out there y'all see bro you all want to
win money or not la mickey
i love mickey castle i like yeah i
actually like lavinky cap you want to
give him some money do i want to go yeah
let's throw him a bag real quick
[Music]
what was your thoughts
about what kareem said about lebron if
you know what kareem said
yeah i mean but yeah i don't know he
called lebron
it was a sensitive celebration you know
for some but
hey you got to let these players
celebrate if they could if they're going
crazy on the court i completely disagree
with it i think there's a big l on my
boy jason because it's a celebration
that people have been doing for a minute
right sam cassell did it like a people a
lot of people been doing it they could
find for it
right he paid his fine good
and then he posted it on his story with
the same same celebration like he don't
give a [ __ ] hey disney center what y'all
think about that
it's kind of i just wanted to say hey
disney disneyland
um
day-to-day davis even even the goats get
things wrong every once in a while and i
just think karate
i don't i honestly think is a little
disconnected who the hell is that
i don't know it's kind of dark enough i
can't really russell's touching his head
and [ __ ] but kareem is you know maybe a
lot of touch he's older you know i mean
back in here
they didn't do [ __ ] i'm gonna say the
opposite about kareem i think he's way
more in touch
than you would expect somebody that's
300 years old i just think he's wrong on
this one subject
he's been right on the majority of the
stuff he's been advocating for the right
stuff for years and years and years oh
well i mean that that type of stuff even
his basketball takes are typically good
is
i don't know i just feel like the older
players always don't
don't really how do y'all feel about
charles barkley
how do y'all feel about charles barkley
blaming the laker situation all on
anthony davis i didn't hear that what
did he say that that came out today
right yeah
like right before this yes
he said that anthony davis pretty much
is the reason why the lakers are
struggling because he's not playing like
a top five player i'm gonna let mike
answer that he's a laker fan
do you think andy davis should be
playing like a top five play in the
league he should be but he don't yeah
that's pretty good there's so many times
where he has he's going to have
mismatches tonight
i i hardly think what did you might tell
me when i was saying that before the
season he told me that was okay right
he did but one thing about them
they're very hypocritical bigs because
they are some of the best bigs of all
time true yeah so they always uh go kind
of crazy on other bigs you know shaq and
dwight feuded for a decade they were
just talking about kristoff's game yeah
as that game was going they're gonna
always talk about the bigs which makes
sense i mean that's what they know
unless they know the big position what
do we expect from uh dennis schroeder
tonight the guy who turned down at 84
million from the los angeles lakers
according to him that was false and that
was never on the table
right it was just conversation
then why did he joke about it
i don't know that's that is i don't
think i don't think i i would joke about
what did tatum switch into
oh not those that's in this case that's
freedom
and it's freedom
i'm not calling it guys
that's his name he legally got ashamed
we called metal world peace metal world
peace no i don't i call him i'll tell
you
what something's going on
before i touch now you changed it one
more time yeah but he didn't stop stop
saying your name there's dennis diaz 71
no longer there's a point side twelve
and a half you're taking over
i'm taking a hundred tonight no i'm
taking over on twitter
the lakers yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah it's the revenge game
everybody gets tf for a revenge game i
think like
we already played yeah we already played
each other and how did he play enough i
know him gave you all like yeah
that's the game i think he was mike
that's what me and you
this is your team i'm rocking with jason
tatum in the celtics i just want to do
that
head up i got the i got the celtics you
got the lakers old school type of bad
ain't [ __ ] points all that great money
line straight money line
what what you how much you're trying to
bet yeah i know you won't be having
money like that so we can do 25.
i'm eating 150. fishy yeah
burger
all right that's called reverse
psychology i dumped it down i
disrespected him by saying he only had
25 so i knew he was going to want to
prove to y'all that he has more money
than that and now i got him to bet what
i really wanted which is 50. okay so
take my course
on gambling let me draw how much
yeah we need some better comments in her
you so you might have to just hop back
i'm jumping in right now
me with that every time brian talk you
got to cover his mouth because if he's
talking he be talking he don't want you
know what
lebron's tears arena again he letting
t.a.c know he's going to indiana in a
couple days
i don't even know for charis leverk i
don't know damn
la flop center sponsored by aarp
that that i like that sponsored by aarp
park
lafontaine really is and they really are
what we got lebron what's the stat line
tonight
uh
28
y'all know who just played on this court
the other day i know you're probably
gonna watch because y'all don't know
he actually played very well
i think they was running better players
than us damn
yeah
they were getting some open looks
you know how though that would be if a
rumor came out that laker stole seven
sierra
canyon place we might have to at this
point y'all think brownie and pro
i don't know enough
yeah i haven't watched much of them
but didn't michael jordan not get
drafted even though he was playing in
college well he was asked
true
i guess i didn't know that
hey brian make a miss next shot who won
the batman who won the batman batman
hundred dollars right now
fake
bet yes alvey in the chest wants to ask
y'all a question he said he missed it i
think i couldn't tell you that okay yeah
it was one of them no
double or nothing doubling
they don't give me a word
they said he's made 17 as far as he's
trying to go crazy with them i'm joking
all right happy birthday to jason tatum
deuce can we get a jason tatum i think
it was
it's too late at this point brother you
wanted him to get 20. that was 15
minutes he had him under 20.
oh oh
yeah i did i forgot what they said oh my
god
oh just coughed me up the bread man just
caught me up the bread can we get
another look at enos cancer shoes uh
freedom whatever his name is
so they allow people to
they allow people to have custom
sneakers that was new like what two
three years ago will you play any color
why haven't they extended that to other
accessories like you remember they were
finding like j.r smith for the supreme
stuff and things like that when would
they allow
different kind of accessories and stuff
i don't think they ever will they want
you to wear the nba accessories yeah
you're promoting more money get involved
i bet they've used some type of
sponsorship up yeah i guess because
since the shoes they're not they don't
have shoes like what did they even say
yeah i'm very political with his
sneakers the past month or so he wearing
elite socks
no those don't play no those are the nba
songs no okay those are nba elites yeah
um oh okay you are i got this yeah i
can't tell you what those are
there's a lot going on on those though i
don't know what they stand for what they
mean
because you remember the last time they
played it i think he wore the lebron one
those aren't even like hoops
quality ones no he wore the shoes that
were talking about lebron
just not wearing no quality somebody
says westbrook west brick warehouse come
on now where are you hey let them know
hey
yo y'all
we're over naming
we're done we're done i like
alliteration westbrook
yeah i like that warehouse westbrook
blocked some of the crypto
the what liquid though
y'all like the look in front of that oh
it's annoying
sometimes it's so bad that that's what
makes it funny like little fishy is
funny because they call them lakovic lee
kovitz
they be too quick like mike like this
[ __ ] he over there that's particularly
here
anything that happens
mr mingo said with his bread yeah
i got you guys what'd he say he's
somebody do i wear money he wanted to
actually accommodate earlier
damn thirsty
right now that [ __ ] gonna come in like
five days what
at me because i looked out for all this
yoga potato that's one
i just started from right there
you know tatum always have big games
against lebron he brought the t up
tonight he does he had 30 and 10 last
time they played earlier yeah 30 like
32. that's his icon it's idol i mean i
know that's not kobe bryant is
this doing something about it
i've literally heard them say it was
kobe yeah what you just gonna say what
he said i'm pretty sure surprised
y'all heard this man nah what are you
saying he said
the bronze is either i said no it's kobe
he said i'm pretty sure it's a prostate
pro i literally watched jason tatum say
kobe is his item [ __ ] just gonna say
[ __ ] what jason tatum said i believe
lebron is really his idol
stat live for lebron 22 10 to 10. i'm
going you didn't change that two times
man you know he asked that same question
yeah i decided to change it up a little
bit i gave him a little bit more 25 five
and five what the bags are right hey i
need to be questioned for them dante d
vincenzo said it would be the kotq
klt4
said it again i don't think anything
about the real dante why wouldn't that
be the real one it's not like you're
playing on that yeah you're trying to
say
we see in the background pretty little
thing that's what it is but i mean you
get that when you go to staples do stuff
like that i've been in the united states
ten thousand dollars to sit down you
might as well get something else give me
a gift of free food drinks every day oh
hey can we get a close-up to lebron
shoes what the hell
what is those the brothers passing with
the shirt without those i think he went
back in time cause those ain't the new
those aren't them
i don't think those are either don't
look like the nines
oh look yeah
those two
what years was he wearing those
well no that was not that nice
or something that's when he first looked
at that yeah
oh yeah hey lebron might get that triple
double matt says he need lebron and
tatum to hit that over tonight i agree
mark said that tatum will be getting 28
seven and eight tonight
who said that mark screen shot that
because if mark gets that right next
week we got him so tip mark you comment
that make sure you hear next week
because if you hit that we got it the
meal screenshot if you screenshot it and
we got you with money if you get we're
gonna start doing that we're gonna we're
gonna start doing who's that line is it
anyway your old to the wire thing and if
y'all guessed it right that's that's how
we're gonna pick one of our winners uh
what about russell westbrook state line
i think that's much harder yeah let's
get a russell westbrook stat line
whoever can get that right
he gonna hit on my prediction okay
eighteen
seven and nine
seventy nine seven one seven nine what
he decides
[Laughter]
what if you have nine turnovers that
that counts
see i wouldn't even throwing no shade i
won't even he always got it though
what you you want to know uh west brick
people huh yeah yeah i have a burner i
figured you had a burner mike
style ass anybody i'm gonna go with give
me one leg celtic
i'm gonna take russell's that line i'm
gonna say it's gonna be
20 points
six rebounds eight assists uh we got
lebron james and yo this is why y'all
lose they playing football
who's that quarterback is that rondo
he hit him with a move whoever was
yeah this is exactly this is why y'all
be losing this is crazy they're not
worried i told you bro this [ __ ] is
another off this is another day and are
we going to see a fist fight between
lebron and his friend he losing the okay
no probably ness cancer ain't gonna do
nothing to after the game i love how
lebron just said he's not the type of
attention to yeah for that celtic though
i'm gonna take marcus smart
bro y'all got a game in five bro like no
[ __ ] i am literally like i've seen
the lakers that's not though but i saw
y'all do this it's the anthony davis i
saw y'all do this when y'all won a
championship i didn't know y'all was
doing this while y'all low 500.
you remember we was in the bubba playing
madden yeah because y'all won the
championship you could do whatever you
want when you win it but y'all can't win
we're not worried
you're worried as a laker fan
people in here are dropping stat lines
but they're not saying who it's four
brooklyn star
big fourth quarter comeback they don't
hey he might have did the over derrick
they say kd hit a big ass shot oh damn
kate k.r grain said a.d need at least 25
and 15.
i don't know about that 15 bullets
24 points
kb he had 24. but they ended up closing
it out yeah besides because i was about
to come on javon carter that was against
the mavericks um
yeah man yeah man the good night reports
about luca coming in 40 pounds over
owen oh
owen gave us multiple stat lines okay he
said taylor's gonna have 36 and four six
rebounds forces
okay dennis schroeder is going to drop
24 and 10 assists damn westbrook is
going to have 22 tennis mellow after the
double negative to play lebron's going
to have 26 6 and 8. damn this is a high
scoring game a.d is going to have 25 and
10 rebounds maybe even start players
yeah maybe maybe he's not saying all
that's going to happen those are just
his guesses but no worries at all this
would be a hell of a parlay
we have decided we're not looking in the
comment section
i like austin reeves might you like
awesome reeves i do
how's the highlights be pushing him he
ain't like he's not like caruso
i wish he had that crucial defense
but he'll be shooting that dude
that's why i said i wish he had the
crucial defense
can we get the br kicks i'm going to
look at the kicks lebron walked in with
let's roll that
because i'm tired of looking at lebron
playing football then when he lose he
gonna be past the progressive in a
post-game interview
talk about yeah man we just need to make
some changes it's not like that's a
lebron b he just say [ __ ] to have
everybody in the locker room on pins
yeah we got guys just they don't want to
play guys not making shots
uh it's not my responsibility to make
shots with guys we paying guys to make
shots that grown ass man
okay
varsity jacket and some forces low
forces okay at first i thought they was
high that's all
a man who a man who has everything walks
in with nothing
that's a metaphor for life about the
same the national uh anthem uh
star-spangled banner whatever you want
to call it um it's almost game time
shout out to the dude who won money mike
and d mills disco mango disco mango
that's a fire name too i like it
and we gonna see y'all next week man we
signing out hey if those stat lines are
right you coming back and you winning
this is through the warm-ups
and we will see y'all next week peace
shout out to narwhal yeah nah why watch
this you know they did
[Music]
you